robots might soon be taking your order
at McDonald's that's right take a look
at this image that was posted on reddit
by snail mail 0:07 he spotted a robotic
McDonald's machine at a restaurant near
Romeoville Illinois and this is where
all of McDonald's latest technology gets
tested first and you know we see all
these things I thought this was
interesting because we don't really see
these at fast-food places or at
restaurants but we do see these like at
CBS and that kind of thing where you
check out yourselves but McDonald's is
not the only food chain that's hoping to
replace human employees Panera Bread is
gonna replace their cashiers all of
their cashiers with robots I guess I
like all those things rope I like Panera
by 2016 you like Panera Bread I do uh
what do you guys make this because there
is an economic part of this which goes
to the story we just did that you know
these companies keep wanting to maximize
profits and Republicans I suppose would
argue if you keep making minimum wage go
higher well then we're gonna have to
fire all these people so that we can
hire robots so where do you fall on has
no there's no number as no you can't
make minimum wage low enough for those
guys not to want to fire people
no not what if there is no no so uh I
would I just read a story yesterday that
you know we're we have we're having this
recovery it is great the jobs are coming
back right but they are coming back they
are not nearly the quality of jobs that
were lost so if this now starts to
happen and that and that people coming
back to finding work at jobs like that
then what's the next job what job do
people take when they come back I'm
pretty sure they're not gonna be as many
robot mechanics as there are cashiers at
McDonald about robot robot masseuse
right Susan
sexpot we talk a lot you get the food
when you punch it in there that is a
failure that is not gonna work you don't
think that's gonna work that it's not
there's no like it's just not be it
doesn't work when there's a person that
well it's likely and what is the problem
with cash do I get cashiers I ain't
talking to a person what I want to order
that's uh no it Mattel's anything
it's moderately cheap in so many places
you know you no longer signing your
credit card yeah you didn't even if you
using your debit card or credit card
whatever it is you just yeah either
through its 573 you know who cares then
you look at your statement at the end of
the month and you're like Jesus I went
to one do you think it's gonna work yeah
here's what I would do yeah it might
work just like the airline you think the
airlines right they all got deregulated
so they all race to the bottom with the
cheapest fares it's and it's only like
now like vertook for 20 years or 30
years for virgin to go hey we're gonna
give you a little bit better experience
it might cost a little bit more so
that's what I think like fast food you
would think yeah fast food chains
booking we're gonna have we have real
people here you know you would also
think that a shoe company would go I
have a billboard up that says we make
our shoes here in America by adults you
think that would that would help you
sell right you'd think they would do all
that but they don't right maybe
they won't do it and we'll just get
over because corporations don't
really provide us choice right well we
did a story a couple weeks ago about how
Macduff's is putting their employees
through online college and I was asking
the guests if they if that would make
you more inclined to go to Starbucks
because even if you have to pay a little
bit more you know they're doing
something socially responsible yeah the
next the next in a mask that
throws a trash can through Starbucks
it's gonna have to deal with this like
like and by this I mean I'm gonna shake
my fist but like Starbucks
they're good and enough with that they
came in and they ruined all the local
coffee there were none local coffee
couldn't get coffee I don't know why the
way Ben has the old-school New York City
I ordered the coffee cup I have so much
disposable income you order that I
ordered these cups so I could fill my
coffee at home with these yeah yeah
that's forgetting the economic part
though do you think that's just
something about losing a little bit of
the human interaction not not that the
people are so great at that look you go
to in and out they're nice they're
smiley and friendly I'm always amazed I
don't know yeah I think they're hopped
up on drugs I don't know what's going on
stones but in McDonald's they're never
friendly or happy to be there or
whatever or not I don't blame them they
work in a pretty crappy job for
low amount of money and we've all done
that and the uniform doesn't help in a
little hat okay fine but do you think we
lose something by eventually if
everything is just robots and
touchscreens I mean we're doing this all
day on our phone anyway and now we go to
get food and we're still doing this all
day then yes we do definitely lose
something we're becoming isolated from
me not only from society but from each
other you know Noam Chomsky talks about
this this is what they want they want
you to be isolated they want you to
think that your thoughts are only your
own and nobody else is thinking them and
all that stuff
this is horrible right yes I think this
is bad I really hope maybe this will
push if they all go robot you know
Wendy's and McDonald's and Burger King
if they all go robots
maybe this will maybe there will be
local burger stands again maybe this
will make that happen you know I've if
Starbucks went all robots maybe there
would be local coffee shops that would
open up I don't think people like buying
food from robots this has been since the
internet age came and I remember a
conversation with one of my friends at
like age 22 23 and he's like you know
you can call and you get your groceries
delivered you have to go to the grocery
store and I was like I want to go to the
grocery store you know I didn't have a
mobile phone then I was like I want to
go the grocery store I want it and like
you know whatever I overreact that it's
nice to be able to call and get your
food delivered if you don't want to but
obviously as we see just you know slowly
20 years 25 30 years you start losing
connections with people and that that
matters people work from home to lose
connections to grocery stores so they
started instituting a few years ago the
no there's no checker there's no cashier
you just go do it yourself which I hate
that it's like hey we'll hey we figured
out a way to cut someone's job out to
people there's no bagger there's no
thing this is gonna be a headache for
you and a pain in the ass but it makes
us more money so I just steal it I steal
whatever I whatever I got machine
whatever you can hand it and that's
that's my way of pushing back all right
final thought I asked this almost every
week one way or another what year do you
predict the robots will take over 2012
they've already taken over I was just
gonna say the same they or they took
over a long time ago Wow
oh that's deep that's deep all right you
mean I'm talking robots like you know
david gregory dory he's getting replaced
by a new feather over your alright with
a goatee isn't that nice so just real
quick that's a better robot that's a
better robot it's a slightly better
I think it's significantly better but
that speaks more to David to the
incompetent nature Dave Greg David
Gregory you know I learned something by
watching the dog whisperer that it
doesn't matter what's inside the dog
because he's gonna make that dog over
ever he wants so the same thing with
Chuck Todd
[Music]